there was one piranha in a swimming pool
would you go in
wouldn't you say get that out of there
but you'll go in the ocean where all the
sharks that aren't in captivity it's an
old joke I use no but it's [ __ ] yeah
it's good and I saw that no I've walked
through the shallow and like surrounded
by sand sharks and stuff fully convinced
the shallow and the shower no way you're
surfing I just wanna know you surf I've
had whales swim under me and stuff it's
amazing that [ __ ] is amazing yeah but I
mean like I've been to the circus I saw
a tiger go right by and I could smell it
that was [ __ ] I could smell it
that was that [ __ ] close it smells
like 50 caps it doesn't mean you know
what Joey enjoy no I'm with you but it's
one of those things that you just can't
like live in fear sort of thing that's
the thing for me well every time I get
in the ocean I'm kind of like going to
the universe like yeah I'll be in your
dangerous part Kumail calls the ocean
God's basement I think that's so funny
and when you go in God's basement you're
like I ain't afraid of your hobby kits
your billiard table I just like how you
just made yourself out to be the stud in
that story I'm going out to the most
dangerous parts of the plan and I'm Pete
Holmes this is a new show of discovery
in the shallow and shallow little badass
hat today I'm gonna stand in the shallow
end with nurse sharks